oh my goodness I played you I guess you
might say forever
probably about 1931 is when I first
started would be 85 years of thought to
me that I've been playing hockey I mark
circuit I'm the oldest ice hockey player
in the world I'm 95 years old hope to be
96 on July 18th I'm still playing hockey
three times a week I get up at 6:00 in
the morning I do my sit-ups my push-ups
and a few other things that kind of
loosen me up and then I'm ready to go
yeah they only live about a mile away
but I do drive down by myself and it's
funny but I'm usually the last one there
I'm the one that lives it closest
the group consists mostly of some former
firefighters and also of course the
current one so there's quite a different
mixture there I think about my age and
once a while I say to myself well you
know you're only 59 you're not 95 I just
turning the numbers are on you make
myself feel better
my love for hockey is is hard to explain
you sweeten with the puck you're
shooting the puck you're trying to take
the puck away from the other guy there's
so many different things you're doing
this it just keeps your going there
everybody's got it wrong I'll keep
distance you you just keep finishing it
better than okay I'll try off if the
coach keeps putting this out there or
doing something right
[Music]
they're the greatest bunch of guys I've
ever played with he sent me up all the
time and sometimes it gets to a point
where I'm almost embarrassed that I'm
not scoring more because they're always
giving me the puck a group of the
players right after hawk eagle come over
to my home and we sit down in the
kitchen and discuss who did what on the
ice and so on and so forth at my age is
a wonderful way of being connected with
the younger people and I think that's
very important for for an older person
I'm so fortunate that it gave me a
chance to be involved it's just really
the best thing that's ever happened to
me in the heart of downtown nairobi
there is a rink that rink is home to an
unnamed ice hockey team
we haven't found a name for the team but
you just call it the whole team
[Music]
my name is banner as a Garrard country
the captain Kenya I saw a league I
decided to play a sake simply because I
wanted to do something different
Kim Kenya many people we grew up playing
different sports like soccer and latex I
just want to do something that's stands
out something unique we have around 30
members in our team we compete against
ourselves
so whoever shows up we divide the equal
number of players then you play against
ourselves there's no money nice work in
Kenya unlike in Europe where we have
leads whereby teams can buy players pay
them well in Kenya just beginning in the
next coming years
ice hockey will be big spots currently
many people are joining and you're
hoping to get even more as pain goes
[Music]
I future dream means for our current
team to be featured in the Winter
Olympics I know we don't stand a chance
but just being there
we might prove the world wrong once you
achieve your dreams there's a
satisfaction that comes with it it is
just a good feeling you like okay we
made it finally
[Music]
my mom thought it was crazy when I told
her I was into underwater hockey and she
continues to think I'm crazy when I show
up with black eyes but she's also my
biggest fan one of other world
championships
my name is tre ullberg and I'm the
captain of the u.s. women's underwater
hockey team
so underwater hockey's played six on six
and we're not wearing tanks just fins
mask and snorkel the puck is weighted
and sits on the bottom of the pool and
players use short one-handed stick to
play the puck unlike ice hockey there's
no goalie and underwater hockey and the
snorkel helps you watch the play while
you're recovering on the surface but
otherwise you're holding your breaths
when you're actually involved in the
play we take underwater hockey very
seriously the u.s. women's national team
impeded the World Championships they're
held every two years and they bring in
about 25 different countries compete to
be the best sort of us it really is the
ultimate team sport because there's no
package that can just do everything for
your team eventually that person's going
to have to come up to breathe and you
have to have a teammate there to take
your place if I'm about to score and I'm
running out of air I'm in a freaking
score
we see people coming to underwater
hockey both from swimming backgrounds
and from ice hockey backgrounds we
struggles from the fact that most people
in the United States don't grow up
playing it people don't grow up holding
their breath and trying to kick hard
underwater they grew up playing soccer
and playing basketball
there's no no money in underwater hockey
so we're absolutely doing it for the
loves of sport
I love underwater hockey it's so elegant
being underwater it's just a beautiful
thing I feel like some really gorgeous
secrets here when I play when were
younger I never thought I looked any
different than her and we didn't
understand why people would be like are
you actually sisters like obviously my
name is Hannah Brandt I played for Team
USA my name is Marissa Brandt and I
played for Team South Korea were sisters
I was born in Seoul South Korea and I
was adopted when I was four months old
I want to play into the States and
that's where I met my parents I started
playing hockey when I was eight and you
started I started when I was about five
years old we did everything together
growing up so really I chose hockey just
to be able to be with her but as I got
older I really learned to love this
sport we played together through high
school and then we went our separate
ways to college
and we're on opposite ends of the world
every day we talk and text and asked
about how each other's days London games
and whatnot so yeah I mean being so far
away we stay connected somehow I think
it's a super cool thing that we're both
going to the Olympics playing for
different teams and in the same sport I
don't know how common that is so I think
it makes it that much more special for
us but I think for our family and
friends that they have two teams to root
for it just so happy to be able to
continue to play the sport I love it be
able to go to the Olympics with this one
[Music]
[Applause]
hockey has shaped and influenced both of
our lives growing up so I can't imagine
a better reason to be able to go back to
my home country it through hockey for me
going to the Olympics is kind of always
been a dream of mine and then to be able
to watch my sister do the same thing and
to be able to go through this experience
with her is just a dream come true a lot
of people may think it's surprising that
somewhere such as Dubai in the middle of
the Middle East would offer hockey
but people want to come and play with us
they're playing for the love of the game
[Applause]
my name is Mike freezing and my play on
is the divine mighty camels to come to a
place where you only can play indoors
and even then it's sometimes it's too
hot the air-conditioning can't keep up
it's quite a bit different than my
experience back home and that's for sure
grew up in rural Alberta Canada so it
was basically in your blood to play
hockey yeah like every kid in Canada we
all dream to play pro someday and now in
Dubai I'm able to do that
[Music]
eh L stands for Emirates Hockey League
and it was created just to get the best
hockey players in the UAE into a
competitive league to build and develop
their local players we have six teams in
the league this year we've had players
that have played pro they've played high
college level in the States high college
level university level in Canada we have
players that played pro in Europe all
different levels in Dubai we don't have
a local team of Emiratis but we play
against the locals in Abu Dhabi and
Denali plane and Dubai Mall exposes it
to a lot more people it really brings
more people to the game you know when
you're in Dubai Mall and your plane and
you're surrounded by a thousand people
who 60% of them probably have never seen
it before
it's it's a special feeling it's it's an
honor to be able to do that obviously I
think it's the best sport in the world
it's great to see that you're making
some sort of contribution to expanding
the sport and promoting it in parts of
the world where it's not natural to be
played
[Music]
you